Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. We are doing the 12 days of Christmas, or indeed the 13 days of Christmas, and we have finally reached the 5th of January. It's the penultimate day, isn't it? Yes, the penultimate day, and an absolute red-letter day in The Rest Is History's calendar, in The Rest is history's calendar and the rest is history's seasonal year because
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎来到《历史的余烬》。我们正在进行圣诞节十二日，或者说圣诞节十三日，我们终于迎来了 1 月 5 日。这是倒数第二天，对吧？是的，倒数第二天，在《历史的余烬》的日历上，在《历史的余烬》和历史的季节年历上，这绝对是一个值得铭记的日子，因为
tom holland happy birthday it is thank you very thank you very much dominic um oh what a lovely moment this is it is and you know how modest i am that i haven't chosen my birthday as one of the two historical events that we're talking about are you going to be doing anything exciting for your birthday tom i don't know because uh when are we recording this it's the uh we're recording it two weeks earlier that's the 23rd of december so i have no idea what we're going to be doing probably staying in under a lockdown or something you should concoct you should have concocted some elaborate story yeah we're going skiing i've never skied i've never been skiing actually never will now i imagine never no yeah um that's a depressing later which to start isn't it um well maybe it No, I've never been skiing, actually. Never will now, I imagine. Never. No.
汤姆·霍兰德，祝你生日快乐。谢谢你，非常感谢，多米尼克。哦，这是多么美好的时刻啊。确实是，你知道我有多谦虚，我居然没有把我的生日当作我们讨论的两个历史事件之一。你生日打算做什么激动人心的事吗，汤姆？我不知道，因为——呃，我们是什么时候录这集的？这是——呃，我们提前两周录的，也就是 12 月 23 日。所以我也说不准我们会做什么，大概是呆在家里隔离或者什么的吧。你应该编造一个，你应该编造一个精心策划的故事。对，我们要去滑雪。我其实从来没滑过雪，以前没滑过，现在我想我永远也不会滑了。不，是的——呃，这是一个令人沮丧的开头，不是吗？呃，也许——不，我其实从来没滑过雪。现在想来，永远也不会了。永远不会。不。
Yeah. That's a depressing note to which to start, isn't it? Or maybe it isn't. I mean, maybe. You can't do anything. Well, I've never had any desire to go skiing, ever. Yeah. It looks horrible. If you'd wanted to have gone skiing, you'd have gone by now.
是的。这是一个令人沮丧的开头，不是吗？或者也许并不是。我是说，也许吧。你什么也做不了。好吧，我从来没有任何想去滑雪的愿望，从来没有。是的。看起来太可怕了。如果你想去滑雪，你早就去了。
I know I'd be terrible at it. I know. I know. Anyway, so, yeah, I'll be celebrating my birthday by not going skiing and probably staying in and shivering. Oh. Because probably by then there'll be power cuts,
我知道我肯定很不擅长。我知道。我懂。不管怎样，所以，是的，我将通过不去滑雪、大概待在家里瑟瑟发抖来庆祝我的生日。哦。因为到那个时候大概会停电，
won't there? Power cuts? What are you on about? Well, Russia will have invaded Ukraine, all the gas will be cut off. Yes, I'm very worried about that, actually.
对吧？停电？你在胡说些什么？好吧，俄罗斯会入侵乌克兰，所有的天然气都会被切断。是的，其实我对此非常担心。
So who knows what will have happened? Okay, well, let's cheer everybody up by talking about some... You know what, Dominic? Yeah. If that hasn't happened,
所以谁知道会发生什么呢？好吧，让我们讨论一些……来振奋一下大家的心情……你知道吗，多米尼克？什么？如果这一切没有发生，
if maybe by the 5th of January, the day today, the Omicron wave will have peaked and passed. There won't have been any power cuts. There won't have been a war. Everything will be great. And people listening to this will have a real spring in their step. They will.
如果也许到了 1 月 5 日，也就是今天，奥密克戎疫情已经达到顶峰并过去了。没有停电。没有发生战争。一切都会很好。听这期节目的人都会感到春风得意。他们会的。
Because they'll see the path that history could have taken. They'll be thinking how bad things might have been. Yeah. But imagine if it's even worse. People listen to this in the bombed out ruins of London. Yeah, terrible. I feel this terrible
因为他们会看到历史原本可以走向的轨迹。他们会庆幸事情本可能会变得多么糟糕。是的。但想象一下，如果情况更糟糕呢。人们在伦敦被炸毁的废墟中听着这个节目。是的，太糟糕了。我觉得这个可怕的
ironic podcast, people laughing. Yeah. As the Omega variant sweeps the world. Oh my word. Tom, don't do this.
讽刺播客，人们在笑。是的。随着欧米茄变异株席卷全球。天哪。汤姆，别这样。
Don't do it. Let's talk about something else. Let's talk, let's go back a thousand years and talk about something from the 11th century. Yes,
别这样。我们换个话题吧。让我们谈谈，让我们回到一千年前，聊点11世纪的事。是的，
and cheer ourselves up with the thought that actually things could be a lot worse because my date is 5th january 1066 and that is the day on which edward the confessor dies and of course the death of edward the confessor the starting gun on the most tumultuous year perhaps in british British history. Yeah. The year that sees the Battle of Hastings, the Norman Conquest, and on Christmas Day, 1066, William the Conqueror crowned in the Great Abbey at Westminster
用“其实事情可能会糟糕得多”这个想法来自我安慰，因为我的日子是1066年1月5日，那是忏悔者爱德华逝世的日子。当然，忏悔者爱德华的死，是英国历史上或许最为动荡的一年的发令枪。是的。这一年发生了黑斯廷斯战役、诺曼征服，并在1066年的圣诞节，征服者威廉在威斯敏斯特大教堂加冕。
that Edward the Confessor had been building throughout his life, and which had been dedicated on the 28th of January, 1065. So a week or so before Edward's death. And that's really the last kind of great event of his reign. And from that point on, he basically takes to bed. He slips in and out of consciousness. He kind of mutters gibberish occasionally and the question that hangs over his sickbed westminster england northern europe is who is going to succeed him as king because he is childless he has totally
这座大教堂是忏悔者爱德华一生都在修建的，并于1065年1月28日落成开光。也就是爱德华死前一周左右。这可以说是他统治时期的最后一个重大事件。从那以后，他基本上就卧床不起了。他意识时有时无。他偶尔会胡言乱语。笼罩在他病榻上空——威斯敏斯特，英格兰，北欧——的问题是，谁将继承他成为国王，因为他膝下无子，他完全
failed to provide an air yeah yeah and he has also basically he's been playing off a pair of candidates yeah harold gobbinson who is the greatest earl in the realm and william the duke of normandy and both of them feel that they have a a claim on the throne there is of course it's actually not up to edward it's up to the wit and because it's kind of an elective monarchy isn't it uh it's it's it's kind of an elective monarchy, isn't it? It's kind of an elective monarchy. But over the previous century or so, the principle has basically been established that it should be a kind of hereditary monarchy. So the hereditary principle should kick in. But what has complicated that is the fact that, as Edward well knows, because his father, Æthelred the Unready, had been kicked out and replaced by the Danish kings, so Svein Fortbeard, Canute, Harth Canute, Harald Harefoot. So there is this kind of idea that the hereditary principle is kind of moderated by violence, rapacity and opportunism and that is basically where harold comes in because
没有留下任何继承人。对，对。而且他基本上也一直在让两位候选人互相博弈。对，哈罗德·戈德温森，他是王国里最强大的伯爵，还有诺曼底公爵威廉，他们俩都觉得自己对王位有某种继承权。当然，这其实不由爱德华决定，而是由贤人会议决定，因为这有点像是一个选举君主制，对吧？——这有点像是一个选举君主制，对吧？它有点像是一个选举君主制。但在过去的一个世纪左右，基本上确立了一种原则，即它应该是一种世袭君主制。因此世袭原则应该发挥作用。但使情况复杂化的是这样一个事实，正如爱德华所清楚知道的那样，因为他的父亲“无准备者”埃塞尔雷德曾被驱逐并被丹麦国王取代——也就是八字胡斯温、克努特、哈索·克努特、金发哈拉尔。所以有一种观点认为，世袭原则在某种程度上受到了暴力、贪婪和机会主义的缓和，而这基本上就是哈罗德登场的背景，因为
there is there is an atheling uh someone who is you know the the word for someone who is qualified to be a king in the form of edgar yeah who is um so there's a there's a kind of a a branch of ethelred's family that have fled to um edmund ironside's family who who lose who um had fought knut to a score draw decades earlier uh and edmund ironside then dies and knut takes over the whole of england um and his family line have been in hungary uh and edgar has come back he doesn't really you know not a native English speaker, doesn't have the kind of the network of connections that a king properly needs. And he's 13 years old.
有一个——有一个埃塞林——呃，某个有资格成为国王的人，那就是埃德加，对，他是一个——所以有一支埃塞尔雷德家族的分支逃到了——埃德蒙·铁侧家族，他们失去了——曾在几十年前与克努特打成平手；而埃德蒙·铁侧随后去世，克努特接管了整个英格兰——他的家族血脉一直在匈牙利；埃德加回来了，但他其实——你知道的，他不是以英语为母语的人，也没有一个国王真正需要的关系网。而且他只有13岁。
So that's no good. So it isn't really any good. So Edward the Confessor, Tom, he's the seventh son of Hethera the Unready. We didn't feature him in the World Cup of English Kings. He wasn't a contender. So first of all, he spent lots of his life. He's half Norman, isn't he?
所以这不行。所以这真的没用。所以忏悔者爱德华，汤姆，他是无准备者埃塞雷德的第七子。我们没有把他选进英格兰国王世界杯。他不是一个竞争者。首先，他度过了他生命中的大部分时间。他有一半诺曼血统，对吧？
His mother is Emma of Normandy. Yeah, and so when Æthelred flees to Normandy, Edward had gone with him, and so had spent a lot of time in the Norman court. So is he kind of more, would you say, more Norman than English? Do you think? Yes. He's yes.
他的母亲是诺曼底的埃玛。是的，所以当埃塞尔雷德逃往诺曼底时，爱德华也随同前往，因此他在诺曼宫廷度过了很长的时间。那么他算不算是——你会不会说他比起英格兰人更像诺曼人？你觉得呢？是的。他是，是的。
Well, he's very, he's very conscious of the fact that he is, he's of the line of the Kurdic ingas. So the line of Kurdic going back through Alfred. Yeah. All the way to Kurdic, the legendary founder of the West Saxon dynasty.
嗯，他非常——他非常清楚自己是——他是库迪因加斯家族的血脉。也就是通过阿尔弗雷德一直追溯到库迪的血脉。是的。一直追溯到西撒克逊王朝的传说中的奠基人库迪。
And that gives, you know, that's a, dare i say a sacral quality to his bloodline the listeners would expect nothing less um but yes but i think culturally he's he's he's as much norman as he is uh anglo-saxon um what about the issue with him and the godwins So Godwin is the big sort of magnate, isn't he? They, they, does he kind of, is he enthralled to them? That, that family?
这赋予了——你知道，这赋予了他的血统一种——我敢说——神圣的品质。听众们也会理所当然地这么认为。嗯，是的，但我认为在文化上，他既有诺曼人的成分，也有盎格鲁-撒克逊人的成分。关于他与戈德温家族的问题呢？戈德温是个相当有权势的大亨，对吧？他们——他是不是在某种程度上受制于他们？那个家族？
He hates them. He hates them. Oh, right. Okay. So, so the Godwins are the kind of the big cheeses. Yeah.
他恨他们。他恨他们。哦，这样啊。好吧。所以，戈德温家族是那种大人物。是的。
Godwin is the Earl of Wessex. Harold Godwin's son succeeds to that. Yeah. And the Godwins, you know, have, have, have become successful as Knut's men. Okay.
戈德温是威塞克斯伯爵。哈罗德·戈德温之子继承了这一爵位。是的。戈德温家族，你知道的，已经——已经——作为克努特的手下取得了成功。好吧。
Right. They're part Danish themselves. Yeah. So Godwin has married a Danish wife. And they basically are the kind of the archetype of the overmighty subject. Yeah. And Edward, basically are the kind of the archetype of the overmighty subject yeah and edward although he has this royal line bloodline he is also you know as we've said a kind of an outsider yeah and so there's an incredible tension um godwin feels that basically he you know he's the big man he has the um the patronage networks.
他们自己也有一部分丹麦血统。是的。所以戈德温娶了一个丹麦妻子。他们基本上就是那种权倾朝野的臣子的典型代表。是的。而爱德华，基本上就是权倾朝野的臣子的典型代表。是的。尽管爱德华拥有这种皇室血统，但正如我们所说，他也是一个局外人。是的。所以这里面存在着难以置信的紧张关系。戈德温觉得基本上他——他是个大人物，他拥有赞助网络。
He should really be running the kingdom. Edward feels that he should. And there's this, you know, they kind of kick each other. Godwin kind of kicks sand in Edward's face. Edward gets back. Godwin's going to exile. Godwin's come back. They kick sand in Edward's face. And basically there's a kind of uneasy truce. And Edward ends up marrying Godwin's daughter, Edith. So Harold's sister yeah and the question of why they never have any children i mean one of the answers may be that edward refuses to allow the grandson of a godwin to sit on the english throne i mean it may be you know that's one of the theories for it okay he just can't bear to go to bed with her um we don't know i mean there's clearly a lot going on there that uh we
他才应该真正管理这个王国。爱德华则觉得应该由他来。于是这就变成了一种——他们互相给对方找麻烦。戈德温会在爱德华脸上扬沙子。爱德华又还击。戈德温被流放。戈德温又回来了。他们又在爱德华脸上扬沙子。基本上这就是一种不安稳的休战状态。最后爱德华娶了戈德温的女儿伊迪丝。也就是哈罗德的姐姐。是的。至于为什么他们俩一直没有孩子，其中一个答案可能在于，爱德华拒绝让戈德温的孙子坐上英格兰的王位。我的意思是，这可能是——这也是其中的一种理论。好吧。他就是无法忍受和她同床共枕。我们不知道。我的意思是，显然那里发生了很多我们
have no way of knowing so would you give edward the confessor low marks for kingship based on the terrible of what happens afterwards yes yeah because because the disaster of the conquest is entirely down to edward and it's not just bad luck that that happens and therefore because he plays he plays he plays harold plays Harold and William against one another. And so both of them can say, well, Edward, you know. So what happens when Edward dies? So with him, and you can see this on the bare tapestry, but it's also reported in a life of Edward that is kind of pretty much contemporaneous,
无从知晓的事情。那么，根据后来发生的可怕事情，你会给忏悔者爱德华的治国能力打低分吗？是的，是的。因为征服之灾完全要归咎于爱德华。这不仅仅是因为发生了厄运，而是因为他玩弄平衡——他让哈罗德和威廉互相猜忌。所以他们俩都可以说：“好吧，爱德华，你知道的。”那么当爱德华去世时发生了什么呢？所以随着他的去世——你可以在巴约挂毯上看到这一点，而且在一部几乎可以算作同时代的爱德华传记中也有记载——
that when he dies, he has Edith. So his wife, Harold, Robert, who's the steward of the, of the, of the palace and the archbishop of Canterbury, who's a kind of a bit of a rogue called Stigand. And this,
当他去世时，他身边有伊迪丝，也就是他的妻子、哈罗德、宫廷管家罗伯特，以及一个有点像无赖的坎特伯雷大主教斯蒂甘德。而这
this account kind of blurs the question of, of, of who it is that Edward on his deathbed nominates. William will claim that it was William and that he'd already nominated him. Harold obviously says it was me. But what this account says is that Edward entrusts the kingdom to Harold rather than granting it. So entrusting could imply a kind of regency for Edgar the Atheling I mean so it's all up for granted but what we know is that
个记载有些含糊不清，没有明确说明爱德华在临终前究竟指定了谁。威廉声称那是威廉，而且他已经指定了威廉。哈罗德显然说是他自己。但这份记载所说的是，爱德华是将王国托付给哈罗德，而不是将其授予他。所以托付可能暗示了一种对埃塞林的摄政。我的意思是，所以一切都未成定局；但我们所知道的是，
Harold is crowned the following day probably in Westminster Abbey and that's incredibly quick and what that also implies is that the Witan must have all been suborned by Harold to back him before Edward dies. And the reason they can do that is that all the great earls and lords have gathered in London, in Westminster, for the consecration of the Abbey. And the two key figures who get squared are Edwin, who is the Earl of Mercia, and Morcar, who is the Earl of Northumbria Morca who is the Earl of Northumbria who are a pair of brothers and Morca marries again another Edith it's all incredibly confusing but Harold
哈罗德在第二天就加冕了，很可能是在威斯敏斯特大教堂，这速度快得惊人。这也暗示着，贤人会议一定在爱德华去世前就被哈罗德买通或施压以支持他了。他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为所有的大伯爵和大领主都为了修道院的落成典礼聚集在伦敦的威斯敏斯特。而其中被拉拢的两个关键人物是麦西亚伯爵埃德温，以及诺森布里亚伯爵莫卡——莫卡是诺森布里亚伯爵，他们是一对兄弟。莫卡娶了另一个人，也是伊迪丝——这一切都令人难以置信地混乱——但哈罗德
Harold marries the sister of Edwin and Morca who is called Edith. Is that Edith Swanwick? No that's a different Edith. Oh god too many Ediths. So there are three Ediths so there's the Eda who is called Edith. Is that Edith Swanneck? No, that's a different Edith. Oh, golly, too many Ediths. There are three Ediths. So there's the Edith who is Harald's sister, who's been married to Edwin the Confessor.
哈罗德娶了埃德温和莫卡的妹妹，她叫伊迪丝。那是天鹅颈伊迪丝吗？不，那是另一个伊迪丝。哦，天哪，伊迪丝太多了。所以有三个伊迪丝——所以有一个伊迪丝叫伊迪丝。那是天鹅颈伊迪丝吗？不，那是另一个伊迪丝。哦，天哪，伊迪丝太多了。这里有三个伊迪丝。所以有一个伊迪丝是哈罗德的姐姐，她曾嫁给忏悔者埃德温。
There's Edith Swanneck, who is the Great Beauty, who is Harald's mistress. Yeah. And then there's Edith who is the sister of Edwin and Morka, who marries Harald, obviously as a kind of pre-packaged deal to get them to back him as king. And so he's crowned on the same day as Edward's funeral.
还有天鹅颈伊迪丝，她是那个绝世美女，也是哈罗德的情妇。是的。然后还有埃德温和莫卡的妹妹伊迪丝，她嫁给了哈罗德，显然这是一笔打包交易，目的是让他们支持他当国王。所以他在爱德华葬礼的同一天加冕。
So there's a lot of kind of indecent hurry going on. Who knew that this podcast would bring so many Ediths? The name of our cat, bless her. Yeah, my paternal grandmother was called Edith. It's an old-fashioned name, isn't it? a great name it's a really great name yeah it's kind of name i think that's kind of coming back into vogue but it's spelt spelt in a kind of very groovy way is it old english yeah it's kind of e a d y g maybe that's just a hassle e a d that'sA-D-G-Y-T-H. Giving your name to bureaucrats, isn't it?
所以这里面有着非常不合时宜的仓促。谁能想到这个播客会有这么多伊迪丝？我们猫的名字，保佑它。是的，我 paternal 的祖母就叫伊迪丝。这是一个老式的名字，对吧？一个伟大的名字，真的是一个伟大的名字。是的，这是一种——我觉得正在重新流行起来的名字，但它的拼写方式非常时髦。是古英语吗？是的，有点像 E-A-D-Y-G，也许那只是个麻烦。E-A-D——那是 A-D-G-Y-T-H。这名字是给官僚们找麻烦用的，对吧？
I mean, so much. It's like kind of Irish people have this hassle, don't they? Yes. I had lots of discussions about this with my wife. I said, if somebody's saying, sorry, how do you spell that? It's no good. That's just going to annoy the child. Anyway, we're getting off to off-piste.
我是说，太多了。这就像爱尔兰人经常遇到的麻烦，对吧？是的。我曾和我妻子就此进行了很多讨论。我说，如果有人问：“抱歉，那个怎么拼？”那可不行。这只会惹恼孩子。不管怎样，我们有点跑题了。
The death of Edward the Confessor. So quite a dark day in English history, Tom. Yes, Tom. Yes, definitely. And after the break, I should be doing a very dark day in French history. We promised you more Gallicisms yesterday, and I have them because we should be talking about the Dreyfus case.
忏悔者爱德华之死。所以对英格兰历史来说这是一个相当黑暗的日子，汤姆。是的，汤姆。是的，绝对是的。中场休息后，我将讲一个法国历史上非常黑暗的日子。我们昨天承诺过你们会有更多的高卢特色，现在我带来了，因为我们要谈谈德雷福斯事件。
Yeah. Okay. That's a very dark day. Yeah. All right. But, but obviously there's a lot of light because it is my birthday. So yes.
好的。那是一个非常黑暗的日子。是的。好吧。但是，显然这里面也有很多光明，因为今天是我的生日。所以是的。
So it's light and shade. All right. See you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to this uh this wonderful day it's my birthday 5th of january um the penultimate uh of the 12 13 days of christmas however you like to
所以这是光明与阴影并存。好的。休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐之余》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦的专属阵地，在我们的问答环节中，我们还会揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的福利，请访问 th
calculate them um and in the uh the first half we did the death of edward the confessor in 1066 and dominic your choice now well before it has a drape you sawed yeah it's a it's a drape you sawed themed uh day but before we come to that since your birthday, Tom, it occurs to me that if the listeners wish to buy you a present... Oh, the very idea! They should go to restishistorypod.com and treat themselves to Rest Is History Club membership.
嗯，我们在上半集讲了1066年埃德ward the Confessor的死，多米尼克，现在轮到你选了。嗯，在它有布景之前，你看到了，是的，这是一个，这是一个有布景主题的，呃，日子，但在我们聊到这个之前，汤姆，因为今天是你的生日，我突然想到，如果听众们想给你买个礼物……哦，天哪！他们应该去 restishistorypod.com，给自己买个“历史的残余”俱乐部会员资格。
Yes. That's what you'd want, isn't it, Tom? That is what I'd want. Of course it is. And if you really love Tom Holland, you could get Athelstan membership, because I know, Tom, nothing would mean more to you than that, would it? Oh, Dominic, I don't want to say that. That's because you want presents on top of that. No, just to be the podcast host of people's hearts.
是的。这就是你想要的，对吧，汤姆？这正是我想要的。当然是。如果你真的很喜欢汤姆·霍兰德，你可以买阿瑟尔斯坦会员资格，因为我知道，汤姆，没有什么比这更能代表你的心意了，对吧？哦，多米尼克，我不想这么说。那是因为你还想以此为借口收礼物。不，我只是想成为人们心中的播客主持人。
That's all I want. Nothing more. So the 5th of January, 1895, we are in the Moulin Court of the military school in Paris. So cadets and so on are assembling. There are 5,000 men in the courtyard of the École Militaire. The drums are rolling. They're all lined up in their finery, in their uniforms. And out of the building come four
这就是我想要的。别无所求。所以，1895年1月5日，我们在巴黎军事学校的穆兰庭院里。所以学员们正在集合。巴黎军事学校的庭院里有5000人。军鼓在滚动。他们都穿着盛装，穿着制服，整齐地排列着。然后从大楼里走出了四个
artillery officers and a fifth man. That fifth man is Captain Alfred Dreyfus, who is an artillery officer born in Alsace. And Jewish, right? And Jewish. That's the key. And he has been
炮兵军官和第五个人。这第五个人就是阿尔弗雷德·德雷福斯上尉，他是一个出生在阿尔萨斯的炮兵军官。而且是个犹太人，对吧？而且是犹太人。这才是关键。而他已经
accused, charged, and convicted of treason, of espionage, of passing secrets to the Germans of all people, the very people who had humiliated France in the Franco-Prussian War. And Dreyfus, and he tears off from Dreyfus's uniform the badges, the stripes. He tears off his cuffs, his buttons, the sleeves of his jacket, and Dreyfus is standing there sort of rigid, utterly rigid you know, like sort of Inspector Clouseau
被指控、起诉并判犯有叛国罪、间谍罪，向德国人——偏偏是德国人——出卖情报，而正是这群人在普法战争中羞辱了法国。而德雷福斯，他从德雷福斯的制服上撕下了徽章和条纹。他撕下了他的袖口、纽扣、夹克的袖子，德雷福斯就那样僵硬地站在那里，极其僵硬，你知道的，就像克卢索探长那样
being decorated at the end of one of the Pink Panther films by the French president for those of you who are Clouseau aficionados he's standing there, he has a tremendous sense of dignity, Dreyfus, while all this is happening to him Dreyfus the traitor, or so it seems and the crowning moment of this is that this officer takes Dreyfus the traitor or so it seems and um the crowning moment of this is that this officer
在粉红豹系列电影的结尾，由法国总统为你们这些克卢索迷们颁发勋章，他就那样站着，德雷福斯有一种巨大的尊严感，尽管这一切都发生在他身上，德雷福斯这个叛徒，或者看起来是这样，而这一切的高潮是，这个军官拿走了德雷福斯这个叛徒，或者看起来是这样，嗯，这一切的高潮是，这个军官
takes Dreyfus's sword and he snaps the sword in two over his knee and at that point that's the point to which Dreyfus physically staggers he sort of recoils and stumbles and then steadies himself and raises his arms. He shouts, innocent, innocent, vive la France, vive l'armée. You have degraded an innocent man, but I swear that I am innocent. And, you know, the watching men, no one moves, no one says anything. And then the men turn and they march off with Dreyfus among them. Dreyfus is taken off to prison.
拿走了德雷福斯的剑，当着膝盖将剑折断成两半，就在那一刻，德雷福斯身体踉跄了一下，他有些退缩、跌跌撞撞，然后稳住身形，举起双臂。他大喊，无辜，无辜，法兰西万岁，军队万岁。你们贬低了一个无辜的人，但我发誓我是无辜的。而且，你知道，周围观看的人们，没有人动，没有人说话。然后男人们转身，带着德雷福斯一起行军离开。德雷福斯被带去监狱。
Initially he's taken to a prison on the Ile de Ré. Yeah, a wonderful place. Yeah, the sort of French Cornwall. Well, Brittany, we said in the previous podcast, was the French Cornwall.
最初他被关押在雷岛的一所监狱里。是的，一个绝妙的地方。是的，可以说是法兰西的康沃尔。嗯，布列塔尼，我们在上期播客里说过，是法兰西的康沃尔。
But this is the holiday destination of choice for the French liberal classes. Yes. And he's held in the Ile de Ré for a month. So then he's put on a ship. And for 15 days, they sail west, and they arrive at the Salvation Islands of French Guyana in South America.
但这是法国自由派阶层首选的度假胜地。是的。他在雷岛被关押了一个月。然后他被送上一艘船。他们向西航行了15天，抵达了南美洲法属圭亚那的萨卢蒂群岛。
And they're on an island called Devil's Island. Which isn't, you know, I mean, if you're going on holiday. No, you wouldn't go to Devil's Island. It is the most notorious, probably the most notorious penal colony on the planet. Yeah, in the world. And the most horrendous sort of conditions. It is the place from Papillon. Yeah.
他们在一个叫做魔鬼岛的岛上。这并不是，你知道的，我是说，如果你要去度假的话。不，你不会去魔鬼岛。它是最臭名昭著的，可能是地球上最臭名昭著的 penal 监狱。是的，在世界上。而且条件极其恶劣。这就是电影《巴比龙》里的那个地方。是的。
So you go there to get to catch fever and die. Yeah, you absolutely do. And there he is, apart from the guards, his guards, Dreyfus is the only inhabitant of the island. And he is put in a stone hut that is about 13 feet by 13 feet in size.
所以你去那里是为了染上瘟疫然后死掉。是的，绝对是这样。除了警卫，他的警卫，德雷福斯是岛上唯一的居民。他被关在一个大约13英尺乘13英尺大小的石头小屋里。
And there he must stay, talking to no one. Rot. Trapped to rot. And you know what? Well, of course you know what. He was innocent. He was right. So the backstory to this, the Dreyfus affair is the most extraordinary
他必须一直呆在那里，不跟任何人说话。腐烂。被困在那里等死。你知道吗？好吧，你当然知道。他是无辜的。他是对的。所以这一切的背景，德雷福斯事件是法国历史上最不寻常的
political scandal in French history. Because it makes Brexit look like a storm in a keycap. It does. It had huge crowds. It had rioting. I mean, in modern terms, that is the closest analogy, isn't it? I think.
政治丑闻。因为它让英国脱欧看起来就像茶杯里的风暴。确实如此。它引发了巨大的人群聚集。它引发了暴动。我的意思是，用现代的话来说，这是最贴切的比喻，不是吗？我认为。
That's what people have said, that the sense of an absolute division in the country. Yeah. People kind of refusing to speak to each other. It absolutely becomes what people would call a culture war. So it becomes ideas about patriotism,
人们就是这么说的，国家有一种绝对分裂的感觉。是的。人们甚至拒绝和对方说话。它绝对演变成了人们所说的文化战争。所以它变成了关于爱国主义的想法，
identity, what is france all this stuff all of these things are kind of heaped up onto this one basically it's a piece of paper in a waste paper basket that is what it's all about yes sorry i interrupted the backstory so the backstory is fascinating so france has lost in the franco-prussian war of 1870-71 and germany has been created off the back of that. And the French feel terribly humiliated because they've also lost Alsace-Lorraine to the Germans. And a lot of people from Alsace play a part in the Dreyfus case story.
身份认同，什么是法国，所有这些东西，所有这些事情都被堆积在这一个东西上，基本上它是一张废纸篓里的纸，这就是全部原因，是的，抱歉我打断了背景故事。所以背景故事非常引人入胜：法国在1870-71年的普法战争中战败，德国正是在此背景下建立的。法国人感到无比羞辱，因为他们还将阿尔萨斯-洛林割让给了德国。阿尔萨斯的许多人在德雷福斯案的故事中扮演了重要角色。
There's lots of people in the army from Alsace. And there's this burning sense of kind of mutilation and humiliation that they want these these territories back but they you know germans germany is the powerhouse of europe so the chances of them getting them back are slim and the french there's a sort of sense in france in the 1890s and so on that there's a kind of a toxicity to politics the political life is poisoned really by the humiliations of the century. And the French are very anxious that the Germans have overtaken
军队里有很多来自阿尔萨斯的人。有一种强烈的残缺感和耻辱感，他们希望夺回这些领土，但是你知道，德国是欧洲的超级大国，所以他们夺回领土的机会微乎其微，而法国人，在19世纪90年代及以后的法国，有一种感觉，即政治有一种毒性，政治生活确实被这个世纪的羞辱所毒害。法国人非常担心德国人已经超越了
them technologically and that they're spying on them and stealing all their secrets. And French military intelligence basically starts spying on the German embassy in Paris. And they have a housekeeper called Madame Bastion who is a she's working for the for the French secret service and then she's basically spying on the Germans and she finds
他们在技术上超越了他们，并且在监视他们、窃取他们所有的秘密。法国军事情报部门基本上开始监视巴黎的德国大使馆。他们有一个名叫巴斯蒂安夫人的管家，她为法国特勤局工作，然后她基本上在监视德国人，她发现
a torn up note in a waste paper basket which becomes known as the bordereau which means I don't know what that means let's say a torn up note anyway she finds this bordereau and she and it's they they stitch it back together and they find that it's basically the details of a gun, of a new sort of hydraulic-powered gun that the French have developed. And somebody has given this to the German military attaché, who's a man called Max von Schwarzkoppen. Basically, the sort of casting agency that supplied the German officers there. And they look around
废纸篓里有一张撕碎的便条，后来被称为“边防备忘录”（bordereau），意思是——我不知道那是什么意思，总之是一张撕碎的便条，不管怎样，她发现了这个备忘录，然后他们把它拼凑起来，发现它基本上是一门大炮的细节，一种法国人开发的新型液压动力大炮。有人把这个交给了德国军事武官，这个人叫马克斯·冯·施瓦茨科彭。基本上就是给那里的德国军官提供人员的那个选角机构。他们四处搜寻
to find out who it is. It must be somebody in artillery, blah, blah, blah. And basically suspicion falls on Dreyfus for two reasons. Well, three reasons, actually.
来查明到底是谁。这一定是个炮兵，巴拉巴拉。基本上，人们因为两个原因怀疑德雷福斯。好吧，其实是三个原因。
Reason number one is that he's from Alsace. So there's this sort of... Alsace has this strange place in the French psyche at this point because obviously it's the territory they want to recapture,
第一个原因是他是阿尔萨斯人。所以有这样一种……阿尔萨斯在此时法国人的心理中占据着一个奇怪的位置，因为很显然这是他们想要重新夺回的领土，
but also people from Alsace, some of them do feel German rather than French. So there is this sort of dubiousness about Dreyfus. Next, Dreyfus is a very chilly character. He doesn't have lots of friends. He's not a man to go to the pub with. Well, he's like the stereotype of a British officer. A little bit, yeah. Chilly, stiff upper lip.
但同时阿尔萨斯人中也有一些人确实觉得自己是德国人而不是法国人。因此，人们对德雷福斯产生了一种怀疑。其次，德雷福斯是一个非常冷漠的人。他没有很多朋友。他不是那种会去酒吧的人。好吧，他就像英国军官的刻板印象。有点像，是的。冷漠，咬紧牙关。
Is he sort of Douglas Jardine? He's Douglas Jardine, yes. And so all that thing you were describing about his refusal to show any emotion, when this unspeakable humiliation, public humiliation is being visited. Oh, a public humiliation, which is literally called a degradation.
他有点像道格拉斯·贾丁？他是道格拉斯·贾丁，是的。所以你刚才描述的关于他拒绝表现出任何情绪的事情，当这种说不出的羞辱、公开羞辱降临时。哦，一种公开羞辱，字面意思被称为“降级”。
A degradation. That's its official title. humiliation, which is literally called a degradation. A degradation. That's its official title. And he, you know, he... Yeah. He draws on the inner ice. He does. And then Robert Harris has an absolutely wonderful novel about the Dreyfus affair.
降级。这是它的官方头衔。羞辱，字面意思被称为“降级”。降级。这是它的官方头衔。而他，你知道，他……是的。他调动内心的冰冷。他的确如此。然后罗伯特·哈里斯写了一部绝对精彩的小说，讲的是德雷福斯事件。
Yeah, it's great. What's it called? An Officer and a Spy, is it? I think something like that. And it's amazing because you know exactly what's going to happen. And you keep telling pages to find out what's going to happen. Yeah, agreed. I think for me, it's actually because you, you know exactly what's going to happen and you keep telling pages to find out what's going to happen.
是的，太棒了。叫什么名字来着？《军官与间谍》，对吧？我想大概是这个名字。这太棒了，因为你明明知道会发生什么。你还是一页一页地往下看，想知道接下来会发生什么。是的，我同意。我想对我来说，实际上是因为你，你明明知道会发生什么，你还是一页一页地往下看，想知道接下来会发生什么。
Agreed. I think it's, for me, it's actually his best novel. And in that, one of the, one of the really interesting things in that is it would be a much more Hollywood story.
同意。我认为对我来说，这其实是他最好的一部小说。在那里，其中一个，其中一个非常有趣的事情是，如果德雷福斯只是那种非常感伤的人，那它就会变成一个更像好莱坞的故事。
If Dreyfus was just kind of terribly sentimental. Yeah. If he was Tom Hanks, but he's absolutely not. He's played by a sort of, he'd be played by some sort of, you know, British character actor who might otherwise be playing Neville Chamberlain
是的。如果他是汤姆·汉克斯，但他绝对不是。他扮演的是某种，他会被某个，你知道的，英国性格演员扮演，否则他可能会去扮演内维尔·张伯伦
or something, isn't he? Jeremy Irons. Yeah. And because he's so unlovable, that kind of gives an extra layer of irony, I suppose, to the story. But, of course, the big thing about Dreyfus is that he's Jewish. And anti-Semitism is really, really rampant in France in the 1890s and 1900s.
或者其他什么人，对吧？杰瑞米·艾恩斯。是的。正因为他如此不讨人喜欢，这大概给这个故事增添了一层额外的讽刺意味。但是，当然，关于德雷福斯最重要的一点是他是犹太人。在19世纪90年代和20世纪00年代的法国，反犹太主义真的非常非常猖獗。
It's a sort of, I don't know, it's a reaction against modernity. It's a search for scapegoats after defeat in war. And there's this all this sort of, there's this kind of Catholic conservative politics kind of bubbling away. And Dreyfus makes the perfect person. And once the military have seized um Dreyfus makes the perfect person and once the military have seized on Dreyfus and they've said it's him they refuse to accept a lot of the officers refuse to accept any questioning or to entertain any doubts at all even as the doubts start worse than that I mean they they start forging yeah they start forging evidence. That's exactly right. And that's what makes it so toxic,
这是一种，我不知道，这是对现代性的反抗。这是在战争战败后寻找替罪羊。所有这些，有一种天主教保守派政治在暗流涌动。而德雷福斯成了完美的人选。一旦军方抓住了……德雷福斯成了完美的人选，一旦军方认准了德雷福斯，他们说是他，他们就拒绝接受，许多军官拒绝接受任何质疑，或者容忍任何怀疑，甚至当怀疑开始的时候——比这更糟糕，我的意思是，他们开始伪造，是的，他们开始伪造证据。完全正确。这就是为什么它如此有毒，
is that actually it kind of ends up where people have to decide either Dreyfus is guilty or the army. Yeah, or the army have been lying to you. Because once the army start forging evidence, and I think they do it at first, the honour of the army is at stake. Dreyfus must be proved to be guilty.
因为实际上它最终导致人们必须做出决定，要么德雷福斯有罪，要么军队有罪。是的，要么军队一直在对你撒谎。因为一旦军队开始伪造证据，而且我认为他们一开始就这么做了，军队的荣誉就危在旦夕。必须证明德雷福斯是有罪的。
And once they've started doing that, because quite quickly, within a few years, suspicion falls on another man called Esterhazy, who is in fact the guilty party. And then it starts to get taken up by kind of liberal or left-wing writers. Most famously,
一旦他们开始这么做，因为很快，在几年内，怀疑就落在了另一个人身上，他叫埃斯特哈齐，他事实上才是真正的罪魁祸首。然后这个事件开始被一些自由派或左翼作家关注。最著名的是
Émile Zola, who writes the front-page story, Jacuzzi, in which he basically says the entire French establishment... Which he writes when he's in exile, doesn't he? Yes, he has to go into exile. Because you see, the Dreyfus case becomes so incendiary that to take a side on it means absolutely... I mean, it's far greater than Brexit,
埃米尔·左拉写了一篇头版文章，题为《雅库齐》，他在文中基本上痛斥了整个法国统治阶层……这篇是在他流亡时写的，对吧？是的，他被迫流亡。因为你看，德雷福斯事件变得如此具有煽动性，以至于表明立场意味着绝对……我的意思是，这比脱欧要严重得多，
far more incendiary than Brexit. It means you absolutely identify yourself politically in the eyes of your contemporaries. And it means that half the country will hate you because either you are on the side of Dreyfus and of sort of justice or you're on the side of the army and the honour of France and the nation
比脱欧更具煽动性。这意味着你在同代人眼中彻底表明了自己的政治立场。这意味着半个国家都会恨你，因为要么你站在德雷福斯和某种正义一边，要么你站在军队、法兰西荣誉和国家一边，
and all this sort of stuff. It's very good in Proust. I've never read Proust. Oh, it's so good. It's really brilliant. It looks terribly long. I mean, it is very long. I mean, it's indisputably very long, but it's as a portrait of French society in this period, it's kind of incomparable. A priest, obviously, would be a Dreyfus partisan, wouldn't he?
以及所有这类事情。这在普鲁斯特的书里写得非常好。我从来没读过普鲁斯特。哦，写得太棒了。真的太精彩了。看起来长得吓人。我是说，确实很长。我是说，它毫无疑问非常长，但作为那一时期法国社会的画卷，它是无与伦比的。显然，一个神职人员会支持德雷福斯，对吧？
Well, because he's Jewish, yes. Yeah. Yes. But people's attitudes to Dreyfus is kind of very useful signifier as to where they stand on a whole host of other issues. So to cut a long story short, I think we should definitely do a whole podcast on the Dreyfus case because it's such a fascinating story.
嗯，因为他是犹太人，是的。没错。是的。但人们对德雷福斯的态度是一个非常有用的标志，表明他们在其他一系列问题上的立场。所以长话短说，我认为我们绝对应该专门做一期关于德雷福斯事件的播客，因为它是一个如此迷人的故事。
But those of you who don't know how it ends probably do want to know how it ends. So Dreyfus is eventually pardoned. He's not exonerated at first. He's basically found guilty again, completely unfairly. But the French president gives him a pardon, which Dreyfus accepts very reluctantly because of course accepting a pardon carries the imputation of guilt uh which he and
但那些不知道结局的人可能确实想知道结局。所以德雷福斯最终被特赦了。他起初并没有被平反。他基本上再次被判有罪，完全是不公正的。但法国总统给予了他特赦，德雷福斯非常勉强地接受了，因为接受特赦当然带有有罪的暗示，而他……
he knows he wasn't guilty but he accepts it he's persuaded to accept it he's not exonerated until 1906 and then he actually serves in the french army in world war one and even then you know nobody really likes him that's the thing even the people who've supported him say, God, he's such a chilly kind of unlovable character. But to who he's become this great martyr. But the interesting thing now is that the French kind of ultra right wing polemicist, demagogue and kind of presidential Eric Zemmour, who is himself Jewish, has brought the Dreyfus case back up again and says,
他知道自己没有罪，但他接受了，他被说服接受了，直到1906年他才被平反，后来他甚至在第一次世界大战中加入了法兰西军队，即便如此，你知道，也没有人真正喜欢他，事实就是这样，即使是那些支持过他的人也说，天哪，他真是个冷冰冰的、不讨人喜欢的人物。但他已经成了伟大的烈士。但现在有趣的是，法国极右翼论战家、煽动家兼总统候选人埃里克·泽穆尔（Eric Zemmour）本人也是犹太人，他又把德雷福斯事件重新翻了出来，并表示，
he thinks Dreyfus was possibly guilty. I think that's exactly what France needs at the moment. To reopen the Dreyfus case. Well, it would make Britain's arguments
他认为德雷福斯可能是有罪的。我想这正是法国目前所需要的。重新审理德雷福斯案。好吧，这会把英国关于脱欧的争论
about Brexit look, you know, restrained and dignified by comparison, wouldn't it? Yes, Eric Zemmour, I mean, he has, so he also thinks that Marshall Petter was unfairly treated and he thinks that Dreyfus was guilty.
相比之下显得克制而有尊严，对吧？是的，埃里克·泽穆尔，我的意思是，他有……所以他也认为贝当元帅受到了不公正的对待，他认为德雷福斯是有罪的。
Shocking. I mean, these seem unnecessary. Plus, yeah, to rip, be ripping off at the moment. This is,
太令人震惊了。我的意思是，这些似乎没必要。而且，是的，现在还要胡闹。这是，
this is not where, if you're just a controversialist, this is just where you end up being led. You just end up... We must not do that, Tom. No, we must stay on the straight and narrow and avoid taking ludicrous positions. Unnecessary polemical positions.
这不是……如果你只是一个好辩之徒，这正是你最终会被引向的结局。你最终会……我们绝不能那样做，汤姆。不，我们必须走康庄大道，避免持荒谬的立场。不必要的论战立场。
We would never do that. We'd never, ever do that. Absolutely not. Anyway, Dreyfus was clearly innocent, so we're not going to do it on the Dreyfus case. So that's the Dreyfus affair. I mean, that is a sad story, I think. Poor old Dreyfus.
我们绝不会那样做。我们绝不会、绝对不会那样做。当然不会。不管怎样，德雷福斯显然是无辜的，所以我们不会去讲德雷福斯案。这就是德雷福斯事件。我的意思是，这是一个悲伤的故事，我想。可怜的老德雷福斯。
That's an incredibly sad story. I mean, well, it's actually, it's a kind of, a slight echo of Torvio as a slave, of kind of dynamics of race leading to, you know, someone being uprooted from the society in which they belong and sent away to, to suffer appallingly away from their family and everybody. Cosmic injustice. Yeah.
这是一个极其悲伤的故事。我的意思是，这实际上有点像托尔维奥作为奴隶的经历，某种种族动态导致某人被从他所属的社会中根除，被送走去遭受可怕的折磨，远离他的家人和所有人。宇宙级的不公。是的。
Cosmic injustice. Um, which I guess is why it still has a kind of resonance that it does today. Yeah. God, this is, this series is getting very depressing. I think we should,
宇宙级的不公。嗯，我想这就是为什么它在今天仍然具有某种共鸣的原因。是的。天哪，这个系列越来越让人沮丧了。我想我们应该，
we've got one more day. Haven't we? We've got a great one tomorrow. A really cheering one series is getting very depressing. I think we've got one more day, haven't we? We've got a great one tomorrow, a really cheering one. We've got one, and we've got the appearance of Samuel Peeps at last. I don't think we've had enough Peeps in these 12 days. No, we've got a very, very, very cheery one tomorrow, which is one of the great days in history. Well, today is one of the great days in history, Tom,
我们还有最后一天。对吧？我们明天会有一个精彩的节目。一个真正振奋人心的节目，这个系列越来越让人沮丧了。我想我们还有最后一天，对吧？我们明天会有一个精彩的节目，一个真正振奋人心的节目。我们有一个，塞缪尔·皮普斯终于出场了。我觉得我们在过去的12天里皮普斯还不够多。不，我们明天会有一个非常、非常、非常振奋人心的节目，这是历史上最伟大的日子之一。好吧，今天是历史上最伟大的日子之一，汤姆，
because happy birthday. And on that note. Thank you. We'll see you tomorrow. Bye-bye. Bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为祝你生日快乐。借此机会。谢谢。我们明天见。再见。再见，感谢收听“历史其余部分”。想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。